[Musique]
bonjour à toutes et à tous c'est Paléo
news l'émission qui fait des news avec
du vieux l'actualité paléontologique de
novembre et de décembre a été très
chargé et on commence immédiatement avec
Tyrannosaurus Rex le dinosaure favori
des tout-petits et des plus grands aussi
qui récemment a fait l'objet de cette
news assez intéressantes vous pensiez
que Tyrannosaurus rex était immense des
scientifiques affirment qu'il était
encore plus grand 70% plus grand nous
dit ici par exemple jeux vidéo.com j'ai
pris le premier article en français qui
sortait sur le sujet je ne fais pas un
acharnement sur jeux vidéo.com ne vous
inquiétez pas c'est juste que jeux
vidéo.com a été parmi les premiers à
traduire la news en français et dans
cette actualité on nous apprend donc
Tyrannosaurus rex dont le poids du corps
est généralement estimé entre 5 et 8
tonnes désormais se voit affublé de de
du poids phénoménal de 15 tonnes voilà
est-ce que Tyrannosaurus rex pesait
deux fois plus lourd que qu'on ne le
disait avant puisque de 15 tonnes c'est
plus que deux fois les sept tonnes
généralement admises pour se tir à nos
enregistre en moyenne et il y a même des
estimations qui poussent le vice jusqu'à
25 tonnes nous dit cet article et
d'autres articles qui ont été liés à
cette news 25 tonnes on est dans du
soropold déjà déjà à 15 tonnes on est
dans du petit soropode 15 tonnes faut
savoir que brachiosaure par exemple sont
le poids minimum qui a été estimé pour
braquer aux Orres c'est très Stone c'est
le moins qu'on ait fait pour braquer aux
ordres donc on est déjà dans la gamme de
variation des tailles qui ont été
proposées pour braquer aux Orres en
brachiosaure c'est un cas particulier
puisque on va de très tonnes à 120
tonnes donc c'est quand même un gros
râteau niveau marge d'erreur mais voilà
on aurait donc Tyrannosaurus rex qui
passe d'un d'un très honorable 7 tonnes
7-8 tonnes à un canonique 15 tonnes
voire 24 tonnes et d'où ça à ça et bah
ça vient du résumé de la du meeting de
la société de paléontologie des
vertébrés la svp en anglais Society of
the break paléontology qui a eu son 82e
meeting annuel qui a tenu son meeting à
Toronto entre le 2 et le 5 novembre de
cette année et donc c'est pour ça qu'il
y a plein de news dans ce Paléo news
parce que il y a beaucoup beaucoup de
choses qui ont été annoncées pendant ce
meeting alors pendant ce meeting
qu'est-ce qu'ils font les gens ils font
des ils font des speechs ils font des
talks chacun a fait un petit un petit
speech de ses recherches de ces
recherches personnelles et dans ce livre
des résumés de fait on a des résumés de
tous ces talk qui ont été faits et il y
en a notamment un ici qui a attiré
l'attention des médias c'est jusqu'à
quel point Tyrannosaurus rex pouvait
être gros un cas d'étude dans
l'estimation de la taille maximum du
corps chez les animaux éteints et Dieu
sait que c'est un exercice périlleux
d'estimer la taille d'un animal
déjà il faut un squelette
raisonnablement complet mon pour tirex
c'est pas vraiment un problème puisqu'on
a beaucoup de squelettes complets de
T-Rex et en plus après il faut imaginer
toute la viande qui avait autour il y a
pas seulement la viande il y a les
organes il y a les il y a les muscles il
y a les les poumons il y a le cerveau
tout d'État d'organe qui ne sont jamais
préservés et qui ont cette fâcheuse
tendance à avoir des densités très
différentes donc des poids par unité de
taille qui sont très différentes un gros
poumon ça pèse beaucoup moins lourd
qu'un gros muscle donc comment on fait
pour estimer la taille du corps bah
comme je le dis c'est un exercice
extrêmement périlleux et comme je vous
l'ai dit brachiosaure par exemple on les
estimations de poids pour braquer aux
ordres vont de threston jusqu'à 120
tonnes donc vous imaginez bien que c'est
un exercice qui est périlleux et qui a
tendance à être fortement imprécis
donc comment on fait pour estimer la
taille du corps de T-Rex à 15 ou 24
tonnes et bien les chercheurs donc
Malone et on alors David Home vous le
connaissez certainement parce que c'est
quand même un grand c'est quand même une
figure connue de la t-rexologie de la
tyrannosauru logique David hone alors je
ne connais pas Malone mais je suppose
que ça doit être un étudiant ou un
collègue et donc ensemble ils ont fait
alors ce qui nous explique dans leur
résumé ici qui fait qui est pas bien
long mais je vous le mettrai en lien ce
qu'ils expliquent dans leurs résumé
c'est qu'ils ont fait de la modélisation
qui prend en compte la taille de
population de tyrannosaures donc ça on
en avait parlé dans un précédent
paléogneuse les tailles de population
chez tyrannosaure elles avaient été
estimées à l'ordre de plusieurs millions
d'individus ceci étant dit ça avait
quand même une marge d'erreur d'un ordre
d'un ordre de grandeur donc un ordre de
grandeur c'est de 10 fois quoi en gros
donc 10 fois supérieur et 10 fois
inférieur une marge de une marge
d'erreur de 10 fois supérieure 10 fois
inférieur à la valeur moyenne c'est
assez ouf comme marge de manœuvre donc
c'était pas très précis mais bref ils
ont utilisé ça ils ont utilisé
ils ont utilisé évidemment les courbes
de croissance de T-Rex les courbes de
croissance estimées de T-Rex puisque
comme j'ai dit on a pas mal de fossiles
de T-Rex donc on a quand même une bonne
idée de comment il grandissait la
longévité moyenne de T-Rex qui est de
l'ordre de l'ordre de 25 à 30 ans
et à partir de ça à partir de tout un
tas de données biologiques qu'on a sur
T-Rex puisque T-Rex est quand même une
des espèces les mieux connues ils
estiment donc
tenez c'est ici la 2,5 millions
d'individus voilà l'information est là
et ce que nous disent Malone et on à
partir de cette de cette modélisation
dont on ne connaît pas vraiment les
détails je préfère tout à fait être
honnête j'imagine que pendant leur
présentation orale ils ont fait ils ont
fait une présentation plus détaillée des
paramètres de leur modèle mais je
n'étais pas là donc on va devoir se
contenter du résumé ils estiment donc
que les plus vieux individus de T-Rex
donc supposément les plus gros il faut
savoir que T-Rex il a une courbe de
croissance qui est très similaire à une
courbe de croissance humaine c'est à
dire que ça grandit doucement au début
ça grandit très vite à l'adolescence et
ça stagne à l'âge adulte sauf que T-Rex
est encore même étant quand même un
reptile puisqu'il appartient au club des
reptiliens les dinosaures sont des
reptiles au même titre que les oiseaux
sauf que les oiseaux ont une croissance
qui est absolument on continue la courbe
de croissance des oiseaux c'est explosif
au départ et après sa plafonne et chez
les mammifères donc c'est l'un ou début
rapide au milieu pendant l'adolescence
et le plafonne à la fin T-Rex il a un
peu une situation bâtarde on va dire
entre les crocodiles et les autres
reptiles et les mammifères et les
oiseaux dans le sens où il a une
jeunesse où il grandit doucement une
explosion de croissance à l'adolescence
un peu comme un mammifère sauf qu'à la
fin de sa vie il va faire comme un
crocodile c'est à dire qu'au lieu de
plafonner bah ça il va continuer de
grandir
donc au lieu de au lieu de rester à la
taille adulte au final T-Rex continue de
grandir comme un crocodile les
crocodiles eux ils ont une croissance
qui est quasiment linéaire à savoir
qu'il grandisse tout au long de leur vie
tant qu'il y a de la bouffe de la place
et du et puis les poissons aussi
d'ailleurs ça vous connaissez bien les
poissons ils continuent de grandir aussi
tant qu'il y a de la bouffe et de la
place ça grandit donc c'est
le T-Rex il est un peu entre les
crocodiles et les mammifères et les
oiseaux dans le sens où ben voilà il a
cette explosion de croissance mais à la
fin il arrête pas de grandir et donc en
partant du principe qu'il arrêtait pas
de grandir bah les plus vieux individus
doivent être plus grands que les plus
gros individus qu'on connaît aujourd'hui
à savoir que le plus gros individu de
T-Rex qu'on a récupéré à l'état fossile
aujourd'hui c'est scotique qui avait été
publié il y a pas longtemps en 2020 vous
voyez donc Scotty qui devait avoir un
âge compris entre 28 et 35 ans on sait
pas trop parce que
ces de ce côté sont très en dirigé par
la vieillesse donc c'est difficile
d'estimer son âge précis on a aussi le
fait qu'il a beaucoup de beaucoup de
marques de traces dedans de blessures de
pathologies etc donc ces eaux ont
vraiment morflé parce que aussi il est
très vieux pour un T-Rex de l'ordre de
28 à 35 ans et c'est vraiment l'âge
maximum des individus qu'on a pu
retrouver pour les tyrannosaures pour
les tyrannosauridés vous voyez ici par
exemple la courbe de vie d'un
tyrannosaure
où vous voyez ici le nombre de
survivants donc très peu de juvénile
nombre de survivants par rapport à l'âge
donc très peu du vinyle beaucoup de
beaucoup de de d'individus de Time de
taille et d'âge moyen et puis chez les
très vieux on a très peu de très vieux
avec les plus vieux qui pareils
atteignent l'âge de 28 ans donc ça ça a
été réalisé à partir d'albertosaurus pas
à partir de Tyrannosaurus parce que
Albertosaurus en a encore plus de
fossiles là vous voyez de l'ordre de
1000 fossiles d'albertosaurus qui ont
été inclus pour faire cette courbe qui
nous indique bien que à partir de l'âge
de 30 ans on trouve de moins en moins
enfin à partir de l'âge de 20-25 ans on
trouve de moins en moins de tyrannosaury
des vivants et ceux qui atteignent l'âge
canonique de 28 ans sont très très rares
sont très très rares et donc ce côté
nous montre qu'ils sont très rares et
qu'en plus ils font la gueule ils en ont
pris plein la tronche alors Scotti c'est
le plus gros il a estimé il me semble à
8 ou 9 tonnes quelque chose comme ça
il y a des marges d'erreurs phénoménales
de toute façon sur les sur les masses
corporelles sur le poids du corps et
donc ce que nous dit ce que nous disent
Malone et one c'est que en fait ce que
dit c'est c'est pas du tout la taille
maximum que pouvait atteindre un T-Rex
pouvait être quasiment deux fois plus
grand que ça de l'ordre de 15 tonnes
avec des détails estimées on peut voir
donc c'est pas dans cette abstract mais
ils se sont exprimés sur certains sites
en anglais et ce sont exprimés en disant
que ils ont calculé pour certains T-Rex
femelle donc les plus grosses
un poids qui pouvait aller jusqu'à 26
tonnes ce qu'il ne considère pas comme
étant tout à fait plausible donc on va
être quand même honnête avec eux 26
tonnes pour eux c'est pas plausible par
contre 15 tonnes ça l'est 26 tonnes
comme je le disais c'est un petit
soropode c'est même pas un petit Soro
pote c'est un soropode c'est un bon
Grosso repose de taille moyenne bien
sympa
15 tonnes c'est trois éléphants
d'Afrique empiler les uns sur les autres
c'est beaucoup c'est beaucoup pour faire
tenir sur deux pattes 15 tonnes à faire
tenir sur une posture bipède c'est
beaucoup donc je sais pas pourquoi 15
Stone ça les choque pas plus que ça
personnellement en tout cas ce qui me ce
qui me ce qui me rend le plus perplexe
on va dire c'est le fait que ben ça part
quand même du principe que tirex devait
pouvoir vivre vachement plus longtemps
que ce qu'on a trouvé jusqu'à présent
dans le registre fossile et y compris
pour des espèces vous voyez qui qui sont
très très bien documentées parmi les
tyrannosaurinés Alberto Zaurus avec
Alberto Zaurus on est aussi proche qu'on
puisse l'être de Tyrannosaurus rex donc
même si on n'a pas 1000 fossiles de
Tyrannosaurus Rex et ça vous le verrez
dans les vous le verrez dans les
comptes-rendus justement de dans les
médias ils disent ah mais on n'a pas
beaucoup de fossiles de Tyrannosaurus
rex ah ça je réponds pas pardon
il y a quand même beaucoup de spécimens
regardez là ils ont examiné 500
spécimens si on avait 500 spécimens de
ça et l'entreprise tiens
si on avait 500 spécimens de Toumaï de
ça et anthropus
génétique quoi donc faut pas faut pas
plaisanter il y a suffisamment de
spécimens et s'il y en a aucun qui
dépasse les 30 ans
c'est quand on va avoir quand même du
mal à argumenter le fait que T-Rex
pouvait dépasser ça de beaucoup et là on
parle quand même d'un truc deux fois
plus lourd donc au moins 50% plus long
parce que
la masse ça ne varie pas la même vitesse
que la longueur la longueur enfin la
masse augmente vachement plus vite que
la longueur c'est de la physique un
volume augmente plus vite qu'une qu'une
longueur linéaire quoi une dimension
linéaire
donc ça donne quand même un animal qui
serait au moins deux fois plus long que
que Stan que Scotty pardon pastane que
Scotty celui-là
et ça fait quand même beaucoup ça fait
quand même beaucoup
donc bref c'est de là que ça vient en
tout cas voilà sachez-le c'est là que ça
vient et donc si vous vous posez la
question non ce n'est pas encore pire
reviewé fallait les résumer sont revus
par les pères mais on a quand même une
tolérance beaucoup plus élevée pour des
résumés de congrès que pour des articles
publiés dans des revues à comité de
lecture comme ce comme cet article là
qui est sorti dans Science et celui là
qui est sorti dans the anatomikal
records donc la tolérance est beaucoup
plus élevée parce que justement on est
curieux de voir donc quand on est
curieux de voir ce que va donner la
présentation bah on laisse sa chance au
résumé puisque si on empêche le résumé
de passer mais on empêche on s'empêche
aussi de voir la conférence
et comme en l'occurrence le résumé
n'explique pas par exemple quels sont
les paramètres inclus dans le modèle on
est très curieux de voir justement ce
qui est dans ce modèle donc ça ça vient
d'un résumer de conférence sachez que ce
n'est pas encore pire reviewé du coup ce
n'est pas encore validé par les Pères et
puis tant qu'on est sur les temps qu'on
est sur ce qu'il se passe à la svp on va
parler de hypnose transsevia
ino37via ou inostranchevia si vous le
prononcez un peu plus un peu plus comme
son pays natal c'est le très très
célèbre gorgonopsien de Russie donc lui
permet supérieur de Russie avec son très
long crâne ses énormes canines à dents
de sabre je vous mettrai une petite
photo là vous l'avez vu partout vous
l'avez vu dans dans Primeval la série
Scénic cutter je crois en français et
puis ce inostrane chez via vous l'avez
aussi vu dans la BBC sur la terre des
monstres disparus puisque c'est lui le
gorgone obtient qui convient dans sur la
terre monstres disparu cette
inostrangelia vous avez donc forcément
déjà vu ou entendu parler de inostrane
chez via même sans vraiment le savoir
même si vous le l'aviez appelé autrement
même si vous l'aviez appelé gorgonaps ce
n'était pas Gorgon apps c'est inostrane
chez via il est beaucoup plus célèbre
d'ailleurs que Gorgon up ce qui est
intéressant puisque gorgonops donne son
nom à la famille des gorgoniens mais
curieusement c'est inostrane chez via
qui est le plus célèbre et donc une
équipe nord américaine et sud-africaine
voyez Christian camerer d'Amérique du
Nord et vous avez ensuite Elis Butler
piaiglietti et Jennifer Botta d'Afrique
du Sud donc une une équipe nord
américaine et sud-africaine nous
rapporte dans ces comptes rendus du
congrès de la Société de paléontologie
des vertébrés que ils viennent de
découvrir un nouveau spécimen
dinostrunchvia non pas dans sa Russie
natale mais en Afrique du Sud dans le
carrous Sud-Africain et alors ce qui a
de formidable je vous mets une niveau du
spécimen ici puisque c'est un spécimen
qui avait déjà été qui avait déjà été
publié même s'il avait pas été identifié
à l'époque donc il y a pas de doute sur
le fait que ce spécimen appartient à une
au stand chez via parce que il a
vraiment ce museau très très long et
très le museau en fait et verticalement
plus haut que la boîte crânienne donc la
vraiment cette forme cette forme du
crâne en forme de V inversé c'est très
très typique de Inno strange chez via
donc il y a pas trop de doute sur le
fait que c'est bien un Inno Stone chez
via et alors il a été trouvé juste 10
mètres en dessous de la limite
permienrias donc c'est à dire vraiment
un pas de temps vraiment très très petit
en dessous de la limite permis Trias
donc c'est il a vraiment vécu juste
avant l'extinction de la fin du Permien
et ça c'est très intéressant parce que à
ce moment là les gorgonoptiens rubidjin
comme Ruby atroce qui était les
gorgonopsiens dominant durant la fin du
Permien et bien ils sont déjà éteints et
ça ça veut dire qu'en gros quand les
Ruby Jean se sont éteints vous avez
inostallunchvia qui a migré depuis la
Russie et qui a envahi la niche
écologique des prédateurs dominants en
Afrique du Sud juste le temps d'un
claquement de doigts géologiques avant
que la limite permet avant que la
l'extinction de la fin du Permien est
lieu et donc ça c'est un témoin
important des perturbations écologiques
qui ont précédé la limite permet un
Trias la limite permet un Trias c'est
pas une extinction qui a lieu
soudainement comme la fin du comme la
fin du Crétacé c'est pas genre bon il y
avait il y a eu un déclin écologique
c'était déjà un peu le bordel à la fin
du Crétacé mais bon il y a pas eu ça une
météorite qui a tout rasé et qui a et
qui a définitivement siffler la fin du
match du Crétacé enfin voilà c'est c'est
pas ça qui s'est passé à la fin du
permis à la fin du permis il y a eu des
grandes perturbations écologiques à
l'échelle mondiale qui ont duré très
longtemps et donc ça avait déjà commencé
plusieurs dizaines voir centaines de
milliers d'années avant la limite
permienriale c'est donc ça c'est un
témoin évident de ces perturbations
écologique le remplacement complet des
des faune de top prédateurs de
prédateurs dominants en Afrique du Sud
c'est un témoin assez évident de ces
perturbations écologiques donc ça on
attend avec impatience du coup que ce
spécimen soit enfin identifié que on
fasse toute la lumière sur cette
extinction parce que c'est quand même
super super intéressant mais revenons à
nos dinosaures avec cet article qui a
été publié dans scientific report donc
une succursale de la revue nightcher et
qui nous annonce la découverte de ce
magnifique fossile dort longue Wangui à
nouveau dinosaure du début du Crétacé
qui appartient à la famille des
droméosauridées donc c'est un raptor
et ce dort longue woogie vous comme vous
pouvez le voir il est exceptionnellement
bien préservé il y a pas un seul os qui
manque donc vous avez le crâne ici le
bras ici vous voyez d'ailleurs le bras
qui est très très long et replié de
cette façon si AVI Vienne j'ai envie de
dire avec vraiment le bras enfin pour
nous ça me donne l'impression que le
poignet est retourné donc ça c'est
vraiment très très typique des des
oiseaux et de leurs proches parent vous
avez ici la fameuse contraction post
mortem des ligaments postérieurs de
blablabla donc qui lui donne cette forme
de U ici il a la tête rejetée vers
l'arrière en gros et ça ça le fait
beaucoup ressembler à la grosse dinde du
film Jurassic Park je vous mets la
petite image c'est le sosie de la grosse
dinde du film Jurassic Park et puis vous
avez les jambes qui sont magnifiquement
préservées les plumes ici et donc ce qui
nous intéresse ici et ce qui est
mentionné dans le titre c'est le contenu
stomacal le contenu stomacal et les
intestins notamment qui sont apparemment
préservés sur ce spécimen et donc cet
article nous présente le fait que les
intestins semblent être plus similaires
à celui d'un crocodile qu'à celui d'un
oiseau notamment parce que les oiseaux
apparemment ont un espèce de muscle qui
ne se voit pas sur le cet état de
préservation on voit les plumes on voit
le contenu stomacal mais les muscles
apparemment on les voit pas trop mais du
coup chez les oiseaux les muscles en
fait repoussent les intestins vers
l'avant alors que alors que là sur celui
là ça ne se voit pas vous voyez les
intestins sont localisés bien bien à
l'arrière de la cavité abdominale donc
apparemment il avait pas un tube
digestif d'oiseaux et là où ça devient
intéressant c'est que Ben vous voyez un
petit peu un petit détail du contenu
stomacal et là où ça devient assez
intéressant bah c'est que le générique
de fin arrive à peu près là sur
l'article on ne nous dit rien d'autre et
si je devais mettre une définition enfin
si je devais mettre une illustration à
ah bah tiens encore un dinosaure chinois
bien préservé
et vous savez avec cette réaction un peu
ah tiens encore un dinosaure chinois
super bien préservé
et bah c'est exactement cet article là
que je mettrai parce que même les
auteurs de l'article ne se sont pas
contentés de plus que ça c'est-à-dire
que l'article c'est une description de
c'est une description assez
superficielle au final puisque encore
une fois on est on est chez nitcher donc
on est on est sur des limitations au
niveau du nombre de mots et on est sur
on demande une efficacité dans le choix
des mots et dans la façon dont les
phrases sont tournées etc etc donc il y
a beaucoup de contraintes sur la forme
mais du coup le fond empathie largement
parce que bah ouais on nous fait donc
une description du squelette qui est qui
doit tenir sur quatre pages donc qui est
assez peu détaillé on nous propose une
analyse phylogénétique qui le retrouve
comme un dromé aux oridés pas de grosse
surprise
voyez la discussion commence là donc
analyse philogénétique
et un paragraphe sur le contenu
intestinal enfin sur le sur la façon
dont les intestins sont organisants nous
parle même pas du contenu intestinal en
réalité et des et du contenu stomacal
donc on ne nous dit même pas ce qu'il a
dans l'estomac et rideau générique de
fin donc c'est une énorme occasion
manquée si je devais si je devais
résumer cet article en une phrase c'est
une énorme occasion manquée
pourquoi les éditeurs qui se sont
occupés de cet article n'ont pas exigé
enfin pourquoi les reviewer d'ailleurs
les fameux pairs qui sont censés relire
cet article pourquoi est-ce qu'ils n'ont
pas exigé qu'ils en face un petit peu
plus parce que c'est quand même une mine
d'information incroyable un fossile de
cette qualité
je sais pas est-ce qu'ils ont est-ce que
ça y est on est atteint le point où les
fossiles chinois super bien préservés
n'ont plus rien à nous apprendre point
d'interrogation
j'ai un doute j'en doute quand même vous
avez pas me dire qu'il y a rien à dire
sur un truc pareil tu vois mais bon bah
en tout cas cet article là ne nous dit
pas grand chose et je vous avoue je vous
avoue avoir été un poil déçu par la
lecture de cet article parce que
vraiment je j'en attends des plus je me
suis fait grave IP de ouf par la qualité
de préservation et je suis tombé de haut
en lisant un article qui était
essentiellement taxonomique voilà
essentiellement à propos de la
classification du truc
on continue avec les dinosaures
maintenant on passe au préféré des
petits et des grands sachant qu'on avait
déjà le préféré des petits et des grands
avec Tyrannosaurus mais donc c'est
Spinosaurus Spinosaurus le fameux le
fameux spinosauridé à Crète dorsale
était-il aquatique il était-il pas
question qui ne trouve toujours pas de
réponse si on en croit donc cette
article par Paul Sereno et ses collègues
donc Paul Sereno on ne présente plus
c'est la figure emblématique de la
dinosaurologie moderne j'ai envie de
dire c'est probablement le paléontologue
le plus connu
il a quand même fait la couverture de la
seule société dans les années 90 ou
début 2000 il a fait la couverture du
Times comme paléont scientifique le plus
sexy du monde donc voilà il est connu et
il a publié dans un journal qui
s'appelle iLife alors que pas très connu
mais qui est cet effet connaître en
publiant les descriptions de homonaleine
notamment donc c'est un journal
respectable et dans cette revue il
arrive il nous explique pourquoi selon
lui et selon son équipe il ne pense pas
que Spinosaurus est aquatique alors
résumé des épisodes précédents il y a
une playlist j'ai fait toute une
playlist juste sur Spinosaurus donc si
vous voulez tous les détails consultez
la playlist là je vais juste vous faire
un résumé super rapide
Spinosaurus il appartient à la famille
des spinosauridés dans lequel on a
Baryonyx par exemple ou succomimus et
donc dans cette famille et irritator
parce que je sais que si je dis pas
irritator on va on va on va mériter
les commentaires en tout cas vont m'y a
été mais bref il y a plein de
représentants dans la famille des
spinosaures idées mais il y a notamment
Baryonyx et donc grâce à Baryonyx on
sait déjà que les spinosaures idées
étaient pissivores du moins on se doute
que les spinosaures idées étaient
pissivores ça a été ensuite confirmé par
des analyses isotopiques par une équipe
de l'ENS de Lyon qui a analysé des
restes de Spinosaurus et qui a montré
que voilà il passait une quantité de
temps significative dans l'eau et se
nourrissait de ressources marines
Spinosaurus lui-même pas Baryonyx donc
les spinozoridés de manière générale on
savait déjà bien avant la grande
publication de 2014 dont je vais parler
tout de suite après on savait déjà on se
doutait déjà qu'ils étaient qu'ils
étaient fortement inféodés au milieu
aquatique pas forcément semi-aquatique
ou aquatique mais au moins un féodé au
milieu aquatique
vient donc la publication de Nizar
Ibrahim et de son équipe en 2014 où il
découvre je crois qu'il y a une image
donc autant l'utiliser voilà où il
découvre la partie des Spinosaurus là
qui est en bleu sur ses squelette
composite donc une paire de jambes un
bassin enfin d'ailleurs c'est juste une
paire de jambes et à bas 5 ils ont
trouvé et quelques vertèbres dorsales
la partie en bleu viendra après enfin la
partie en bleu sur la queue viendra
après donc il trouve cette paire de
jambes et il la décrivent et du coup ils
en profite pour faire une grande
révision de tout ce qu'on sait ou quoi
savoir sur Spinosaurus et ce qu'ils
disent c'est que bah Spinosaurus il a
quand même les narines qui sont poussées
loin vers l'arrière donc en position des
vents très très loin d'ailleurs vers
l'arrière beaucoup plus loin que sur un
crocodile donc Spinosaurus il a ses
narine poussait très loin vers l'arrière
il a donc il a des jambes qui
apparemment sont sont très très petites
par rapport au reste du la proportion
des jambes a été très très débattue mais
c'est vrai que
le problème étant essentiellement que on
n'a pas de bras attaché à une paire de
jambes sur un seul et même squelette de
Spinosaurus donc là ce que vous voyez la
paire de bras elle est en jaune les
jambes elles sont en bleu parce que
n'appartiennent pas au même spécimens
donc c'est difficile de dire si la paire
de bras était aussi vieille que la paire
de jambes surtout en partant du principe
qu'il continue à grandir même à l'âge
adulte
je vous renvoie l'article sur
Tyrannosaurus dont on vient juste de
parler donc si continuer à grandir à
l'âge adulte une paire de bras adultes
et une paire de jambes adultes sont pas
forcément censé être la même taille sur
deux individus différents bref on
continue donc on a tous ces éléments là
qui sont ensemble qui nous indiquent une
certaine proportion de certaines
proportions et notamment que les gens
vont l'air d'être plus petite que les
bras et avoir des jambes relativement
faiblarde c'est aussi un caractère qu'on
retrouve chez les animaux
semi-aquatiques ceci étant dit le sacrum
qui est la partie où le pelvis ou le
pelvis donc le la ceinture pelvienne
s'accroche à la colonne vertébrale à
quatre vertèbres comme tous les autres
théropodes donc
si le si le bassin est bien accroché à
la ceinture à la colonne vertébrale il y
a pas de raison de penser que les gens
étaient particulièrement faibles mais
bon les gens ont l'air quand même
vachement petites même comparé aux
vertèbres auxquels elles sont
directement attachées
et donc on a ces proportions on a le
fait que les griffes sur les pattes
arrières sont pas hyper développés ce
qui est quand même inattendu pour un
carnivore et puis à partir de ça donc et
de plein d'autres de plein d'autres
petits arguments mais surtout cela ils
ont fait l'hypothèse que spinosaurise
devait être semi-aquatique voire même
capable de nager à l'époque il l'avait
reconstitué avec une palmure on va
mettre les points sur les i
immédiatement sur la palmure sur les
pieds on le saura jamais ça fait partie
des caractères qui sont impossibles à
reconstruire c'est c'est pas la peine de
c'est quand vous voyez un dinosaure avec
pas le mur c'est super mais si c'est pas
un canard on en a aucune idée
que les choses soient très clair il y a
pas de Corée là
ostéologique direct d'une palmure on
peut avoir des doigts très très longs
enfin on peut avoir des orteils très
très long et pas avoir de pas le mur ça
arrive plein de fois chez plein
d'animaux différents donc c'est pas la
peine en fait de d'utiliser ça comme un
argument la palmure c'est pas un truc
qu'on est capable de reconstituer sur un
fossile donc bref le ils font
l'hypothèse du coup basé sur tous ces
arguments là que Spinosaurus passait
quand même une certaine temps dans l'eau
via après ça une nouvelle découverte
celle de la queue de Spinosaurus publié
alors je sais plus si c'était en
2017-2018 ou 2019 mais peu importe vous
le verrez dans la dans la playlist via
ensuite la queue de Spinosaurus qui est
aplatie comme celle d'un crocodile donc
elle est aplatie la queue osseuse
évidemment quand vous regardez la queue
d'un crocodile elle est pleine de
muscles donc elle a pas l'air aplati
mais quand vous regardez le squelette
elle est aplatie verticalement et donc
ça ressemble beaucoup à la queue d'un
crocodile et qui de et donc ils font
l'hypothèse qu'elle devait onduler et
permettre à Spinosaurus de nager donc à
partir de là Spinosaurus non seulement
à des petites jambes qui semblent
indiquer qu'il ne passe pas beaucoup de
temps sur Terre
à des narines repoussées vers l'arrière
qui semblent indiquer qu'il passe
beaucoup de temps la tête sous l'eau
avec juste les narines qui dépassent et
maintenant à une queue aplati qui semble
indiquer que il pouvait nager avec la
queue alors encore une fois ça a été
extrêmement débattu est-ce que la queue
pouvait réellement bouger comme ça
beaucoup de gens ont remarqué qu'il y
avait des attaches musculaires assez
faibles dessus beaucoup de gens ont
remarqué que les que tous que toute la
queue en général la structure de la
queue semblait extrêmement fragile donc
ça avait peu de chance d'être
utilisé pour la nage mais bref
ça ressemble quand même vachement à ce à
quoi on s'attendrait d'un animal qui
utilisait sa queue pour nager soyons
tout à fait honnête donc le le on va
dire que le cas d'un Spinosaurus au
moins semi-aquatique s'épaissit un petit
peu et puis via un article en 2019 ou là
ils ont fait des couples dans les eaux
de Spinosaurus et là ce qu'il voit est
assez impressionnant puisqu'il voit que
les eaux de Spinosaurus sont hyper
denses on appelle ça de la
pachyostéosclérose donc ils sont hyper
denses et hyper épais et ça c'est une
signature quasiment parfaite je dis
quasiment parce qu'il y a certains
animaux qui ont des eaux paquiostéo
enfin qui ont des membres pas qui
ostéoscléotique donc très épais très
dense mais qui ne sont pas semis
aquatiques ni aquatique du tout
d'ailleurs
mais c'est vraiment c'est vraiment un
caractère qui a quasiment une qui a une
corrélation un pour un avec un mode de
vie au moins semi-aquatique
pas totalement aquatique puisque les
cétacés et les ichtiosaures par exemple
eux n'avaient pas des eaux à qui
ostéoscléotique quand on devient un
animal pélagique un animal de hotmer on
perd la palioostéosclérose mais tous les
animaux se mi aquatiques ou presque ont
des eaux packyostéosclérotiques très
épais très dense et on découvre ça donc
chez Spinosaurus et pas chez ses proches
parents le Baryonyx et le succomimus ou
en tout cas moins développé donc on a
quasiment et on a même d'ailleurs une
série évolutive ou on a de plus en plus
de paquetsostéosclérose en se dirigeant
dans l'arbre phylogétique vers
Spinosaurus alors là à partir de là
je pense que le débat a été complètement
plombé parce que non seulement on a donc
de la morphologie mais maintenant on a
en plus par dessus on avait de l'isotope
et maintenant en plus on a de
l'histologie qui nous dit non mais là
sérieux il était semi-aquatique je veux
dire il pouvait nager voilà il a le il a
l'équipement pour nager il a un
équipement assez médiocre pour se
déplacer sur terre il a les adaptations
classiques à la vie semi-aquatique
notamment les narines rétractées et
maintenant on lui trouve de la
pachyostéosclérose bon
ce serait n'importe quel autre animal
mais là c'est Spinosaurus mais là ce
serait n'importe quel autre animal le
débat il serait plié mis dans une
enveloppe et puis le jour où vous avez
des vrais arguments pour contester ça
éventuellement on la rouvrira
mais là c'est Spinosaurus et c'est là
qu'on arrive à cet article donc qui nous
présente tout un tas d'arguments contre
une interprétation de spizanosaurus
comme étant aquatique il y a eu entre
deux d'ailleurs j'y pense il y a eu
entre deux un autre article qui était
coécrit je crois justement par David
hone qu'on a vu un peu plus tôt et j'en
avais parlé de cet article dans un
précédent Paléo news parce que dans cet
article en gros il disait mais non
Spinosaurus il est pas aquatique et il
nous faisait à mille-feuille un exemple
typique de millefeuille argumentatif et
cet article il ressemble un petit peu
dans le sens où dune ils essayent
d'utiliser plein d'arguments différents
mais c'est surtout ce qui n'est pas mal
en soi mais c'est surtout le côté où en
fait on crée un faux dilemme à la base
en disant soit Spinosaurus et terrestre
soit Spinosaurus et aquatique et c'est
pas du tout c'est pas du tout c'est pas
du tout juste en fait de dire
nizarry Brahim en gros c'est faire la
distinction entre terrestre et aquatique
comme s'il y avait pas de continuum
entre les deux et du coup ça fait deux
fêtes
Sereno il faut un peu la même chose que
comme je l'ai dit avec l'autre article
ils font un peu ce faux dilemme du C
terrestre ou c'est aquatique ou c'est
complètement terrestre en oubliant un
peu le continuum à montrer les deux et
est-ce que Nizar Ibrahim m'a dit c'est
effectivement il se trouve quelque part
en fait sur ce continuum probablement
plus proche de l'aquatique que du
terrestre voilà ça c'est ce qu'ils ont
dit donc là il conteste ça et en
contestant ça du coup ils vont apporter
des arguments et certains de ces
arguments sont valables d'autres leçons
je trouve un peu moins le premier c'est
ils ont fait un espèce de modèle en fait
de Spinosaurus donc une modélisation 3D
de du corps de l'animal avec les tissus
mous pour le pour essayer de faire des
tests de sa flottabilité et alors c'est
vrai que il y avait il y avait eu des
des reprises de ces images hors contexte
c'est à dire si vous prenez juste cette
image là de du pauvre Spinosaurus en
train de flotter comme
une grosse merde sur l'eau effectivement
vous allez avoir du mal un combat entre
les gens qui étaient capables de nager
donc ils font une modélisation et puis
évidemment le Spinosaurus n'a pas l'air
de flotter correctement
parce que son centre de gravité
semble-t-il et trop
encore une fois c'est un modèle c'est
une modélisation ils ont mis des
paramètres dans ce modèle des paramètres
que eux jugent correcte mais que
probablement Nizar Ibrahim va
s'empresser de contester dans sa
prochaine publication à propos de
Spinosaurus donc c'est le problème des
modélisations c'est qu'on fait une
approximation de la réalité mais qu'on a
des choix de paramètres de modélisation
qui peuvent être plutôt arbitraires donc
là peut-être que ils ont pas mis la
densité osseuse enfin peut-être qu'ils
n'ont pas utilisé une densité
osseuse que nizary Brahim et son équipe
validerait peut-être qu'ils ont utilisé
des poumons et des et des ramifications
des sacs aériens ce qu'on voit ici qui
sont trop développés pour pour ce que
nous arrivera il met son équipe voudrait
valider j'ai pas la prétention d'être
expert en Spinosaurus mais je dis
jusqu'à modèle c'est le un modèle
n'explique que les paramètres qu'on y
injecte que donc si vous injectez des
paramètres qui sont contestables par
d'autres équipes vous avez obtenez un
modèle qui est contestable par d'autres
équipes
donc ils ont fait ça ils ont comparé
encore une fois la queue avec
l'efficacité de la nage de la queue
d'autres animaux et pour eux la queue
n'est pas un bon propulseur chez
Spinosaurus mais ça ça avait déjà été
dit avant
là il compare la longueur des membres
chez Spinosaurus et trouve que les
membres sont très différents de ceux
d'un ictusord d'un mosasaure et d'un et
d'un crocodile bon ça ça je suis pas
extrêmement surpris on va dire que
Spinosaurus il est semi-aquatique est
devenu semi-aquatique
est devenu un animal semi-aquatique en
partant d'un plan d'organisation
dinosauriens théropodien donc je
m'attends pas non plus à ce qu'il
ressemble à un crocodile au niveau de
ses proportions on a évidemment la
question de la palmure qui est discutée
ce qui nous rappelle d'ailleurs au
passage que les crocodiles n'ont pas les
pieds aussi pas le MEXA au final
il y a cet argument qui a été utilisé
qu'on a trouvé des spinosaures très loin
à l'intérieur des terres donc évidemment
à l'intérieur des terres de l'époque
puisque la mer est en niveau plus haut
au Crétacé retrouver des spinosaures
dans le Sahara c'est pas non plus une
grosse surprise mais là en l'occurrence
même en prenant en compte les paléos
ligne de rivage les lignes de rivage
telles qu'elles étaient au crétacées ils
ont retrouvé du spinosaure jusqu'au
Niger voilà c'est ce qui est indiqué ici
Spinosaurus SP maxillaire droit qui
vient de du centre du Niger donc ce
maxillaire là qui a été trouvé ici donc
il y a du Spinosaurus au Niger et donc
ça selon eux ça veut dire qu'il n'y
avait pas de que Spinosaurus pouvait
marcher et que donc il n'était pas un
féodé au milieu aquatique ce que nizarn
Ibrahim et son équipe n'ont jamais dit
c'est encore une fois c'est le la
question du faux dilemme de
soit il était soit c'était un dauphin
soit c'était un animal terrestre et rien
entre les deux non Spinosaurus il a
encore des pieds il est encore des
jambes il est encore des pieds encore
fonctionnels jamais personne n'a remis
en question le fait que les gens étaient
fonctionnels donc je vois pas pourquoi
ce serait un argument qui invaliderait
totalement et puis il faut pas oublier
aussi l'écrasante l'écrasante
abondance de Spinosaurus dans des
environnements deltaïques on retrouve
énormément de Spinosaurus dans les
environnements deltaïques quasi
exclusivement dans des environnements
deltaïque alors je sais qu'il y a un
billet de fossilisation qui a beaucoup
de choses qui se préservent dans les
environnements deltaïques pas seulement
les spinosaures idées mais bref ça faut
pas non plus effacer cette dimension là
mais et puis trouver des animaux
aquatiques à très loin à l'intérieur des
terres c'est pas nouveau puisque on a
par exemple les baleines à bec dans des
milieux dans à 17 millions d'années dans
la vallée du Rift on retrouve on a
retrouvé un fossile de baleine avec les
baleines à bec c'est quand même les
animaux sa vie un peu comme les
cachalots les baleines à bec c'est à
dire que ça plonge c'est un animal
vraiment extrêmement pélagique
extrêmement loin des côtes donc on
retrouvait un dans la vallée de La Fare
enfin dans en Afrique de l'Est là c'est
pareil ça ça devrait pas se produire
mais bon le registre fossile est
suffisamment gigantesque pour qu'on
trouve des anomalies partout donc
qu'est-ce qui prouve que ce maxillaire
n'est pas une anomalie pour l'instant on
n'a qu'un seul fossile donc c'est pas
non plus impensable donc il y a tout un
tas d'arguments comme ça qui sont
présentés et donc au final la grande
conclusion on note d'ailleurs que leur
nouvelle reconstitution elle ne donne
pas une une crête carrée vous voyez
comme c'est on est revenu à la crête
ronde c'est plutôt marrant et à la fin
de leur article Sereno et ses collègues
nous proposent une liste de 13 points
qui sont les conclusions principales de
leur étude donc je vais vous les lire
rapidement les adultes de spinosaure
devaient avoir une longueur de 14 mètres
bon ça ça ne ça ne conteste ni ne prouve
quoi que ce soit en matière de
locomotion aquatique ou terrestre les
jambes réduites de Spinosaurus et leur
remplissage sont plutôt des adaptations
pour soutenir le poids du corps que pour
agir en tant que ballast donc leur
argument principal étant que
les tissus qui remplissent les ossements
de Spinosaurus ne sont pas les tissus
qu'on que ne sont pas exactement les
mêmes tissus osseux que ce qu'on
retrouve chez les animaux
semi-aquatiques modernes
en tout cas pas chez tous
est-ce que ça change quelque chose au
niveau fonctionnel je veux dire étant
donné le nombre de fois où des
opaquillostéosclérotiques ont dû évoluer
au sein des tétrapodes est-ce que ça
changera quelque chose au niveau des
conclusions j'ai un doute mais en tout
cas c'est quelque chose qui le propose
ici donc pour eux le même la
paquiostéosclérose n'est pas un bon
argument pour dire que Spinosaurus alors
que pour moi c'est vraiment pour dire
que Spinosaurus est semi-aquatique alors
que pour moi à mon avis c'est l'argument
le plus important donc pour eux ça ne
marche pas
l'épine orale de Spinosaurus et GIPS sur
sa sur sa queue n'est pas ne pouvait pas
agir comme un propulseur donc pour eux
leur modélisation ça ne marche pas
Spinosaurus était bipède et se déplacer
de façon bipède sur la terre les bras
avant n'était pas utilisés comme support
sur la terre alors ça c'est un argument
c'est un argument je suis même pas sûr
que Nizar Ibrahim et son équipe en ont
parlé dans les articles peut-être qu'ils
l'ont dit dans les encore une fois dans
les dans les médias mais je suis pas sûr
qu'il les proposait dans les articles je
me rappelle pas de ça ceci dit j'ai pas
fait mes devoirs donc je vais pas être
trop positif là-dessus mais c'est un
truc que les Paléo artistes ont beaucoup
repris pas forcément on y croyant mais
en tout cas c'est un truc qui a été
beaucoup repris parmi les paléo-artistes
ceci dit je connais pas grand monde qui
est ré enfin en tout cas au sein de la
communauté scientifique qui est
réellement mordu à cet hameçon là
d'ailleurs je pense
pouvait s'aventurer dans des eaux peu
profondes et chasser à jusqu'à 2 mètres
6 de profondeur bon donc il confirme que
Spinosaurus égyptien accuse était au
moins semi-aquatique donc là c'est la
fameuse théorie du héron de la chasse en
mode héron mais encore une fois cela ne
conteste l'hypothèse de nizary Ibrahim
que si on caricature l'hypothèse de
Nizar Ibrahim en disant que Spinosaurus
c'était un dauphin qui nageait avec la
queue or ce n'est pas ce qui indique les
données fossiles la pachyostéosclérose
n'est pas présente chez les animaux
pélagiques donc là c'est vraiment le
côté plongeur le côté
Spinosaurus allez vraiment dans l'eau
qui qui est contesté là qui qui allait
nager dans l'eau
la reconstitution de Spinosaurus indique
qu'il pesait 7 tonnes ce qui lui donne
une densité inférieure à celle de l'eau
en gros et donc une densité inférieure à
celle de l'eau fait que tu flottes donc
ça c'est ce qu'ils disent mais c'est ce
que leur modèle dit mais encore une fois
on met dans un modèle les modèles
n'expliquent que les paramètres qu'on y
a inclus et peut-être que Nizar Ibrahim
et son équipe ne serait pas d'accord
avec les paramètres de ce modèle mais ça
on le verra je suis sûr qu'il va y avoir
une publication qui va répondre à ça
Spinosaurus égyptiencus n'était pas
capable de plonger étant donné la
densité qu'il avait au dessus et étant
donné que son que ce que ces côtes
n'étaient pas compressibles mais encore
que là étant donné le peu de matériel
qu'on a en articulation je me demande
d'où ça sort
et il aurait fallu que sa queue soit 25
à 15 à 25 fois plus puissante pour lui
permettre justement de compenser cette
cette baisse cette faible densité de son
corps pour pouvoir forcer à l'intérieur
de l'eau il aurait fallu que ça que soit
15 à 25 fois plus puissante ce qui est
encore une fois appliquerait
appliquerait des
impliquerait des muscles gigantesques
bon ça c'est pour compenser justement le
problème de la flottabilité le problème
de la flottaison ça vient aussi des sacs
aériens et des poumons tels qu'ils les
ont reconstituées et peut-être encore
une fois que quelqu'un d'autre
jugerait par exemple que Spinosaurus
vivait ses poumons avant de plonger ce
que font beaucoup d'animaux aquatiques
aujourd'hui donc ils vivaient ses
poumons et stocker l'oxygène dans ses
muscles par exemple comme le font les
dauphins
ça peut être une contestation assez
facile de cet argument là mais encore
une fois c'est plus au spécialiste de
Spinosaurus de nous dire quel était le
volume des sacs aériens si on se base
sur la morphologie des vertèbres
puisqu'on a les trous des sacs aériens
dans la morphologie des vertèbres donc
c'est là qu'il faut
c'est là qu'il faudrait focaliser une
réponse je pense
Spinosaurus n'était pas stable dans les
eaux profondes c'est le petit le jouet
là qui flotte qu'on a vu tout à l'heure
et donc il n'aurait pas pu exercer une
force suffisante pour se propulser bon
ça on l'a déjà vu tous les animaux
strictement aquatiques de grande taille
donc plus grand que 2 mètres sont
strictement marins alors que les
fossiles de Spinosaurus sont aussi
trouvés à l'intérieur des terres bon bah
ça je vous ai donné l'exemple de la
baleine à bec tout à l'heure qui fait
définitivement de mettre ou plus et qui
a été trouvé très très profondément à
l'intérieur des terres ceci étant dit ça
reste quand même des dépôts marins donc
là il y a vraiment il y a vraiment ce
côté strictement marin qui est ajouté à
l'argument on va dire mais bon c'est
peut-être aussi parce que pour les
espèces vivantes des animaux marins de
plus de 2 mètres à part les baleines
enfin à part les cétacé il y a pas grand
chose il y a peut-être les Syriens qui
peuvent être je sais même pas la rétine
ouais si la rétine de stellaire mais
déjà on est plus sur de existant on est
sur de l'animal éteint et donc chez les
animaux éteints le fait est qu'on a
peut-être aussi un problème de registre
fossile bon donc ça c'est pareil c'est
contestable c'est assez facilement
contestable la transition vers un milieu
semi-aquatique en gros ce qui nous dit
c'est ne sait fait que chez des animaux
de petite taille or chez Spinosaurus on
aurait soudainement un animal qui
deviendrait un animal de grande taille
qui deviendrait semi-aquatique donc
l'argument c'est que toutes les
transitions vers un milieu aquatique se
sont faites chez des petits animaux qui
sont ensuite devenu gros donc par
exemple elle s'est assez était petit
quand ils sont devenus semis aquatiques
et après ils ont grossi donc là
Spinosaurus lui il était déjà gros voilà
c'était déjà des animaux de grande
taille les spinosauridés avant de
devenir ensuite semi-aquatique et ça ça
s'est jamais vu effectivement dans le
registre fossile des tétrapodes
mais encore faudrait-il qu'il y ait une
raison théorique pour ça ce qui m'a pas
l'air d'être le cas pourquoi est-ce
qu'il y aurait pourquoi est-ce qu'en
théorie on ne s'attend pas à ce que ça
arrive en pratique ça ne s'est pas
produit ça je suis d'accord mais
pourquoi quelle est la raison théorique
derrière ça parce que s'il y a pas de
raison théorique pour laquelle ça c'est
pas produit bah peut-être que c'est
juste la faute à pas de chance
Spinosaurus égyptien que c'est
interprété comme un animal semi
aquatique qui vivait sur la côte et
était un prédateur embusqué
qui était un peu plus inféodé au milieu
aquatique que les barres liquidés par
exemple
ça oui mais bon ça n'exclut pas le fait
qu'il pouvait savoir nager
et encore une fois si il vivait que sur
le encore une fois s'il vivait que sur
le bord pourquoi avoir les narines
reculées alors il y en a qui ont proposé
que c'est parce qu'il plantait juste le
museau dans l'eau mais pourquoi dans ce
cas s'il plantait que le museau dans
l'eau avoir aussi des os très très épais
et très dense
alors il dit que c'est pour le soutien
mais le soutien pourquoi pourquoi dans
ce cas Tyrannosaurus parce que
Spinosaurus il est peut-être plus long
que Tyrannosaurus et Giganotosaurus mais
il est pas plus lourd
Tyrannosaurus était autrement plus lourd
là par exemple ils nous disent que
Spinosaurus faisait 7 tonnes je vous ai
dit tyrannosaure il fait au moins 7
tonnes voire 8 tonnes voire même jusqu'à
15 tonnes si on en croit l'article dont
on a parlé tout à l'heure mais bref
Tyrannosaurus il fait au moins le même
poids que
Spinosaurus voire même un peu plus donc
pourquoi est-ce qu'on voit pas ces mêmes
adaptations chez Tyrannosaurus et chez
Giganotosaurus par exemple ben c'est un
peu le problème de cet argument là donc
il faut arriver à expliquer pourquoi il
aurait des eaux plus denses ce
Spinosaurus pourquoi avoir des eaux plus
denses alors que d'autres animaux qui
ont le même poids n'ont pas besoin de
d'eau plus dense pour soutenir ce même
poids donc moi je veux bien croire si
vous voulez que la pâquilleostéosclérose
peut être une adaptation à autre chose
qu'un milieu semi-aquatique mais c'est
probablement pas l'explication fournie
au dessus qui est
qui est que c'est pour du soutien
du support de du poids de Spinosaurus
donc oui oui certes il pouvait vivre sur
le bord des côtes et explorer le bord
les côtes à la recherche de nourriture
et de poissons etc mais pour aller
chercher son poisson et pour pouvoir
expliquer toutes ces adaptations dans un
milieu semi-aquatique va falloir à mon
avis ça reste plus raisonnable quand
même de dire que Spinosaurus était
semi-aquatique encore une fois
si c'était n'importe quel autre espèce
éteinte on aurait déjà plié le dossier
mais c'est juste parce que c'est
Spinosaurus et que Spinosaurus waouh ça
fait vendre ça fait vendre du papier
les spinosaures idées sont vécu sur un
bref intervalle
et avec un habitat aquatique mais en
même temps mais en même temps pas si
aquatique que ça d'après lui il y a deux
faces d'évolution dans les adaptations
au milieu aquatique chez les
spinosauridés la seconde donc celle
respi chez Spinosaurus distingue les
spinosaurinés des dinosaures non naviens
les plus semi-aquatiques d'accord
donc ils admettent quand même que
Spinosaurus était fortement fortement
fortement semi-aquatique donc ça est-ce
que c'est un énorme papier pour dire
qu'on n'est pas d'accord mais on est
d'accord
je sais pas en fait ça conteste ça
conteste essentiellement que Spinosaurus
utilisait sa queue pour nager et était
un plongeur en fait mais ça conteste pas
tellement le fait que Spinosaurus était
aquatique du coup
ce qui est ce qui est l'opposé de du
titre j'ai envie de dire du de l'article
donc je vous mets cet article en
description vous pourrez aller vous
pourrez aller le télécharger vous faire
votre propre opinion mais en tout cas je
en fait finalement la conclusion c'est
bien que Spinosaurus passait un temps
non négligeable dans l'eau et tout ce
qui est contesté au final c'est juste
est-ce qu'il plongeait ou pas et est-ce
qu'il nageait avec sa queue ou pas c'est
plus ou moins juste ça le cœur du débat
quoi il y a pas tellement de doute sur
le fait que Spinosaurus était aquatique
quoi candise le titre de cet article on
continue avec les dinosaures
semi-aquatiques avec un nouveau
dinosaure semi-aquatique qui nous a été
présenté il y a très très peu de temps
là c'est vraiment une des toutes
dernières découvertes au moment où
j'enregistre ce paléone news c'est NATO
Venator qui nous vient de la Mongolie
chinoise
et qui est finalement un proche parent
du al scaraptor voyez elle scarabtor est
ici dans cette phylogénie des des
Théropodes enfin plus précisément des
droméosauridés donc de la famille des
Raptors de manière générale donc ici on
a natho Venator et alsk Raptor qui sont
branchés tout à la base ensemble dans
une famille qui s'appelle les alscar
aptoïd donc NATO benator c'est un proche
parent du alskarator qui avait défrayé
la conique puisque c'est le c'est le
petit dinosaure le petit Raptor qui
ressemble à un signe mais tout le monde
avait dit en voyant le fossile oulala ça
sent le faux ça sent le ça sent le gros
fake la fabrication
puisque il y a beaucoup de ces fossiles
de Mongolie et de la Mongolie chinoise
qui sont trafiqués enfin qui sont
trafiqués dans le sens où on en fait du
trafic on en fait de l'exportation
illégale et qui sont trafiqués dans le
sens où ce sont des assemblages de
plusieurs spécimens ensemble ça leur
donne un peu ce genre d'aspect bâtard
qu'on voyait très bien sur le scarabtor
c'est à dire un coup de signe très très
long une anatomie des jambes qui a pas
l'air d'aller avec l'anatomie du crâne
au final ils avaient fait des des études
au synchrotron de Grenoble qui avait
montré que d'une part il y avait une
cassure qui avait l'air de courir le
long de tout le spécimen donc c'est la
même cassure le long de tout le
spécimens qui a l'air de soutenir que
tout le spécimen appartient au même
animal mais surtout il y avait dans le
niveau des des vertèbres et au niveau du
du compte du nombre de cercles de
croissance en fait le nombre de cercles
de croissance était à peu près le même
partout sur l'animal donc si c'est un
assemblage de plusieurs trucs de
plusieurs fossiles c'est quand même un
énorme coup de bol qu'ils aient trouvé
des fossiles qui ont tous le même âge
vous savez donc apparemment
même si j'ai toujours du mal à le croire
et bel et bien quelque chose de legit et
donc là on a NATO Venator maintenant qui
vient d'être découverte qui vient aussi
donc de Mongolie enfin de la Mongolie
chinoise qui date aussi du Crétacé et
qui ressemble beaucoup à scarabtor ce
qui a l'air et là il ressemble pas trop
à un faux là ça ressemble vraiment à ce
à quoi les fossiles de Mongolie donc
c'est le désert de Gobi devrait
ressembler et ce scaraptor
ce NATO Venator du coup ressemble
beaucoup à scarabtor ce qui fait que ça
ça a l'air de quand même soutenir que
alska Raptor c'est l'egit que alkarator
n'est pas un fake puisque comme Aska
Raptor il a cette tête de canard
ce long cou de signes cette anatomie
très fusiforme très gracile un corps
très fuselé de manière générale donc il
a vraiment tout de dual scarabtor voyez
là ils l'ont même reconstitué avec un
coup de signe ce qui veut pas dire
forcément que c'était exactement comme
ça qu'il tenait sa tête mais en tout cas
ils l'ont fait exprès pour que ça
ressemble à l'image canonique qu'on a
maintenant de alskar Raptor et donc ce
NATO benator ils disent que c'est un
dinosaure semi aquatique parce que il a
des narines rétractées comme Spinosaurus
il a une sorte de bec de canard ce qui
est très pratique quand même pour
filtrer l'eau comme le font les canards
et il a selon eux les côtes tournées
vers l'arrière c'est ce qu'on voit ici
ce qui lui donne un corps justement très
hydrodynamique et de ce fait il
reconstitue Sonato Venator comme étant
un animal qui ressemblait à un signe et
qui était semi-aquatique et pour le coup
il lui ont pas mis de palmure au pied
bon c'est bizarre de reconstruire de
reconstituer un animal semi-aquatique
qui se déplace comme un canard qui
ressemble à un canard mais qui a pas les
palmure d'un canard mais bref
ça c'est juste ça c'est juste de la
licence artistique il y a rien il y a
rien de très scientifique derrière ça
alors que penser de ce NATO Venator bah
moi ça me fait beaucoup ça m'intéresse
beaucoup ça me fait beaucoup rire parce
que je suis à peu près sûr et certain
que personne ne va compter que NATO
Venator était semi aquatique alors même
que ça fait 10 piges qu'on nous emmerde
avec spinosaure
donc tout le monde va faire son petit
NATO son petit dessin de NATO Venator en
train de nager sur Twitter et personne
va contester ça par contre ça fait 10
piges qu'on nous emmerde avec un débat
sur est-ce que Spinosaurus était
semi-aquatique ou pas sachant que là les
deux seuls caractères qui soutiennent
que NATO Venator et semi aquatic c'est
il a une gueule de canard
et il aurait des côtes tournées vers
l'arrière mais très honnêtement
regardez-moi le fossile tenez il y a le
son là les côtes en articulations donc
s'il y en a quand même des côtés en
articulations je suis mauvaise langue
mais c'est déjà ça n'a jamais été un
argument historiquement reconnu comme
étant très très fort en faveur d'un mode
de vie semi-aquatique il y a aussi plus
intéressant mais qui n'ont pas utilisé
là pour comme argument une adaptation à
mode de vie aquatique c'est l'absence de
pleure au sel sur les vertèbres y
compris les vertèbres les vertèbres
cervicales donc les vertèbres cervicales
n'ont pas de sac aérien en tout cas ne
montre pas de signes que des sacs
aériens étaient présents chez un
droméosauridé c'est très très
particulier on est très très proche des
oiseaux il devrait y avoir des sacs
aériens sachant que les sacs aériens
sont là depuis le Trias il devrait être
là chez les plus proches parents des
oiseaux ils ne le sont pas et ça c'est
si les sacs aériens étaient
effectivement absents chez NATO Venator
le la densité du corps aurait été
effectivement tel que plouf il aurait
coulé
un peu comme un crocodile donc ça ça
aurait été un argument intéressant mais
il ne le développe pas cet argument là
il n'utilise pas l'absence de pleure au
sel comme étant un argument vous voyez
c'est écrit ici les plus recel sont
absents ils ne l'utilisent pas comme un
argument en faveur d'un mode de vie
aquatique et évidemment ils n'ont pas
regardé la densité osseuse parce que je
sais que c'est le premier truc que vous
allez me demander ils n'ont pas regardé
la densité osseuse pour pouvoir nous
dire si oui ou non la densité osseuse
était élevée chez NATO Venator donc ça
ça attendra plus de travail mais voilà
ce que je trouve intéressant c'est que
ça c'est ça c'est publié dans une
succursale de nature qui s'appelle
communication biology donc encore du
journal prestigieux
et encore une fois ça a pas vraiment et
ça n'a pas vraiment été questionné par
les les reviewer quoi et encore une fois
je trouve ça je trouve ça dommage que
que qu'il y a eu un peu un petit peu de
laxisme là sur Ben attends on va
peut-être falloir donner un peu plus
d'arguments pour dire qu'il était semi
aquatique votre truc donc c'est encore
un exemple où je trouve vous la [ __ ] a
pas été suffisamment enfoncé sur le sur
le système de revue par les paires je
pense mais bref ça reste une découverte
intéressante et qui confirme et qui a au
moins l'intérêt de confirmer que alska
Raptor n'était pas fake c'est à dire que
même maintenant même maintenant si on
devait découvrir que alskaractor et fake
on a quand même NATO Venator et de ses
petits cousins là qui nous indiquent
qu'il y avait quand même des d'autres
animaux qui avaient cette morphologie
très similaire à celle de la scarabtor
donc même si elle scarabtor est fake on
sait que l'anatomie générale le plan
d'organisation générale de l'animal lui
survivra et puisqu'on puisqu'on parle de
d'animaux mésozoïques aquatique je
voulais juste vous parler de pratique
alors qui était pas encore publié au
moment où j'ai enregistré mais qui est
sorti avec une faute de frappe
absolument hilarante
stable body plane and adaptative
et en haut lieu d'écrire stable ils ont
écrit table et dans ce stable ça m'a
immédiatement fait penser à furax
donc ça m'a juste extrêmement fait rire
bon allez je vais vous présenter quand
même rapidement ce que raconte l'article
mais en gros c'est la découverte d'un
nouvel animal qui se branche c'est
anosaurus qui nous vient comme vous
pouvez le voir du Trias inférieur de
Chine
et donc c'est le début du Trias de Chine
elle s'appelle anosaurus et c'est un
animal en fait qui est le plus ancien et
le plus basal des soropterrigiformes
c'est-à-dire de la famille des
plésiosaures et des autosores et des
placodons donc c'est le représentant le
plus basal et ce qui a de très marrant
en fait c'est qui ressemble à aucun des
trois enfin le crâne ressemble quand
même un peu à celui d'un autosaure comme
vous pouvez le voir c'est un petit
animal c'est pas bien gros
mais vous voyez le corps est assez
fusiforme assez gracile les côtes sont
extrêmement papilloteuses sclérotiques
là pour le coup ça se voit très très
bien les côtes sont très très épaisses
les membres sont aussi très courts et
très épais fortement pas
cryostéosclérotique là il y a même pas
besoin de couper pour savoir que c'est
pas qui ostéoscléotique là ça fait trois
fois l'épaisseur que c'est censé faire
il y a aucun doute là-dessus donc ça
c'est vraiment l'animal le corps d'un
animal aquatique vous voyez c'est quand
même différent de ce qu'on voit chez
Spinosaurus et de ce qu'on voit chez
NATO Venator
ça c'est un animal qui est
définitivement sans aucun doute
fortement aquatique pas encore pélagique
probablement à cause de la
pachyostéosclérose mais ça vit déjà 100%
de son temps dans la mer à part
éventuellement pour pondre quoi et on
voit déjà quand même le début de du
bassin qui commence à former cette
plaque ses grandes plaques qu'on va
retrouver plus tard chez les
plésiosaures de façon hyper développée
pareil pour les coracoïdes ici ça
commence déjà à former des plaques il
ressemble un peu à mes osaurus de
manière générale donc c'est une petite
découverte petite découverte bien
intéressante avec le petit le petit le
petit fou rire au passage faible
ancestrale body plane of art
[Rires]
et on termine avec les tétrapodes
semi-aquatique toujours dans la revue
communication biology mais cette fois on
remonte dans le temps on va dans le
Paléozoïque au Carbonifère nous sommes
il y a plus de 300 millions d'années
quasiment 320 millions d'années au début
du Carbonifère et nous allons rencontrer
watcheria qui est un amphibien et alors
watch Aria qu'est-ce qu'ils ont fait ça
vous voyez le squelette de watch heria
ici ils ont pris des fémurs de watchria
à différents stades de croissance alors
quand je dis il c'est une équipe
nord-américaine essentiellement ils ont
pris des fémurs de watchria ils les ont
organisé par différents stades de
croissance juvénile à l'adulte et en
coupant à l'intérieur ils ont découvert
qu'en fait watcheria grandissait très
très vite beaucoup beaucoup d'os
fibrolammellaires chez watch ria donc là
ce fibre lamelaire c'est l'OS où on voit
pas bien voir pas du tout
l'esprit de croissance l'esprit de
croissance étant un signe plus elles
sont marquées plus on a une croissance
lente chez watcheria on a des canaux
inversia qui indiquent que les
os sont remaniées très rapidement des
canaux inversiens se sont juste des
vaisseaux sanguins enfin des traces de
vaisseaux sanguins dans l'os qui
indiquent que l'OS était fortement
remanié donc fortement en train de
grandir et on a de l'os fibrolammellaire
c'est-à-dire pas ou peu ou très peu
marqué de street de croissance ce qui
indique encore une fois que que l'animal
se en fait grandissait exactement comme
un animal à sang chaud
au Carbonifère au début du Carbonifère
chez un amphibien donc des animaux qu'on
ne suspecterait jamais au grand jamais
d'être à son show et d'ailleurs je même
en voyant ça je ne remettrai pas en
compte l'idée qu'ils étaient à
sang-froid enfin externe du coup c'est
juste que on peut être ectotherme et
grandir extrêmement vite voilà ce que
démontre watchria et ça ça tire à balle
réel sur tout un tas de conception qu'on
croyait qu'on croyait pouvoir s'asseoir
dessus confortablement et se dire ok ça
c'est stable c'est bon je peux rester
non là ça ça vous enlève tout ce que
vous avez sous le pied que vous croyez
solide toutes ces choses bien établies
que vous dont vous vous imaginez qu'on
pouvait
dont on pouvait se servir pour pouvoir
reconstituer l'évolution des
métabolismes et notamment du sang chaud
et du sang-froid chez les espèces
éteintes et ben vous les prenez et vous
torchez avec et vous jetez tout ça à la
poubelle voilà voilà
donc ouais cette étude là c'est
probablement la plus importante de tout
ce paléoz je l'ai pas mis en premier
parce que c'est pas Tyrannosaurus ni
Spinosaurus évidemment mais clairement
ça ça va [ __ ] la merde ça va
clairement [ __ ] la merde et dans 10
ans on va encore en entendre parler de
ces gens qui ont pris un amphibien qui
ont coupé à l'intérieur et qui ont dit
ah merde ça grandit ça grandit comme un
animal à sang chaud bon bah les gars le
sang chaud en fait c'est pas comme ça
qu'on saura
ou alors l'hypothèse c'est que watch
Aria était déjà à sang chaud mais on est
je rappelle on est au Carbonifère donc
juste après l'origine des tétrapodes je
veux dire
au début du Carbonifère tic-tac hier
c'était juste hier donc au début du
Carbonifère on s'attend absolument pas à
ce qu'ils a métabolisme à sang chaud
mais en plus on s'attend certainement
pas à ce que ça se reflète sur le
et puis de toute façon non pardon de
toute façon on est sur des trucs qui se
comportent de manière générale comme des
amphibiens on appelle ça des amphibiens
bon c'est paraphilétique les amphibiens
on est bien d'accord mais on appelle ça
des amphibiens parce que ils avaient un
comportement amphibien ils avaient une
biologie d'amphibiens ils avaient des
métamorphoses comme les amphibiens il
faisait tout comme les amphibiens c'est
bête là c'est pas des c'est pas des
reptiles on est vraiment regardé là si
je vous montre sur la phylogénie hop
whatcheria il est là et regardez il est
juste à côté à quant au stega il est
juste là vous voyez c'est juste avant et
juste à côté vous avez [ __ ] d'herpès donc
un des tous premiers amphibiens je crois
que c'est le premier à avoir juste 5
doigts vous voyez avant ça ils avaient
encore 8 doigts donc là vous avez
pederpès juste à côté vous avez Gérard
péton donc tout ça c'est c'est de
l'amphibien très très basal
qui n'est même pas encore suffisamment
dérivés pour qu'on puisse les rattacher
aux amphibiens modernes c'est encore
moins dérivé que les amphibiens modernes
donc c'est un truc c'est un truc de fou
de voir vous voyez bah d'ailleurs les
amphibiens modernes sont là les lisses
amphibiens donc ça là c'est les
dernières endroits où on s'attend à
trouver
un animal endoterme un animal à sang
chaud et pourtant il grandissait très
vite et ça c'était un truc qu'on avait
déjà observé chez les crocodiles
modernes c'est pas non plus complètement
révolutionnaire mais de la croissance
osseuse très rapide on avait aussi
observé ça chez les crocodiles modernes
donc là ça enfonce le clou
définitivement que une croissance
osseuse rapide c'est pas forcément un
signe dans deux termes donc ça c'est un
article qui change vraiment tout qui
fout le bordel et comme je l'ai dit on
va encore en entendre parler
restons au Paléozoïque remontant un
petit peu maintenant au Permien toujours
dans la revue communication biology je
crois que c'est une revue qui viennent
de lancer c'est pour ça qu'ils ont lancé
plein d'articles d'un coup mais bref
toujours dans Communication biology
un nouveau la gerstad du permis à moyen
d'Afrique du Sud qui s'appelle undercaru
qui vient d'être publié par ma collègue
rose prevèque et qui est une recherche
donc
internationale de manière générale mais
essentiellement sud-africaine et
française puisque vous avez aussi
andrénel qui est Paléo anthomologues à
au Muséum d'histoire naturelle de Paris
donc une cour recherche
sud-africaine française et ici vous avez
Mike Day qui est britannique bon c'est
quand même une recherche essentiellement
internationale on est bien d'accord mais
quand même avec une contribution
franco-sud-africaine que j'apprécie
énormément
et donc dans ce nouveau la gerstadt on
n'a pas des tétrapodes mais cette fois
on a surtout des végétaux des
glossopteries c'est notamment parmi ces
glossoptérises des infructésences de
glossoptérises on parle pas de fruits on
parle d'infrerence donc c'est on parle
pas de fleurs ni de fruits on parle
d'infruitescence pour que l'eau Terrisse
on n'est pas encore chez les plantes à
fleurs donc de magnifiques
infructésences de glossostérisme et on a
des larves d'état de larves et de
fossiles d'adultes aussi d'insectes et
autres arthropodes voyez ici ça va
regarder cet acarien il y a même pas
besoin d'être spécialiste en fait pour
voir que ce truc là est un acarien voyez
des ailes d'insectes absolument
magnifique
des détails très très fins qui
permettent une identification très
précise même si moi j'y connais rien
donc je vais pas vous je vais pas vous
bullsiter votre face avec ça on a des
nymphes regardez cette nappes magnifique
et ici on a notamment les
paléodihtioptères
les fameux trucs du Paléozoïque qui
ressemblait à des libellules mais qui
avait une deux trois pairs au lieu de 2
donc les paléolithesoptères ça c'est une
nymphe de paléodie Octave donc
apparemment on avait un genre de petit
de petit environnement bon là ils disent
deltaïque mais deltaïque très calme avec
une déposition de sédiment très très fin
où les animaux les arthropodes venaient
pondre leurs œufs ou les nafes venaient
se développer et donc ça c'est très
intéressant parce que ça va nous
apprendre plein de choses vu que c'est
du permis à moyen ça va nous apprendre
plein de choses sur à quoi ressemblait
la l'entomophones avant l'extinction de
la fin du mois d'aoopia et avant
l'extinction
permienrias donc pour l'instant c'est
juste la présentation du site de manière
générale il y a pas il y a pas de
grosses découvertes présentées là à part
le fait que on a à nouveau site on a une
préservation de taré et ça va nous
apprendre plein de trucs dans le futur
voilà c'est pour l'instant c'est là
qu'ils en sont on passe maintenant au
mammifère on rem maintenant l'arbre
évolutif là on était redescendu
jusqu'aux amphibiens on remonte
maintenant chez les mammifères dans la
lignée des Synapsides et on va
directement attaquer avec du mammifère
du vrai les chiens domestiques de quand
c'est que ça date alors on a déjà fait
une vidéo tout entière avec un chercheur
spécialisé je vous la mets en
description sur l'évolution l'origine du
chien domestique mais en gros pour la
faire courte et c'est très bien résumé
dans ce dans cet article là tout à la
fin de cet article là vous avez deux
grosses de grosses hypothèses sur
l'origine du chien domestique une qui
dit que le chien était domestiqué entre
10000 et 17000 ans
quelque part au Moyen-Orient ou en Chine
ou entre les deux on sait pas trop ou
peut-être en Europe de l'Est on sait pas
trop c'est essentiellement les
généticiens qui défendent ça et ceux qui
étudient du coup cette région du
Croissant fertile
qui défendent l'hypothèse que le chien a
été domestiqué par là et donc ça
donnerait au chien une histoire qui
serait finalement assez similaire à
celle des autres animaux domestiques à
savoir une domestication qui aurait eu
lieu
dans le Croissant fertile au début du
néolithique donc avec l'apparition de
l'agriculture et puis vous avez
l'hypothèse qui place l'origine du chien
beaucoup beaucoup plus tard beaucoup
plus beaucoup plus tôt pardon il y a
entre 40 000 et 35000 ans qui est
soutenu par quelques fossiles il y a
notamment ce fossile d'un chien qui date
de 33000 ans d'Europe de l'Est qui a
dans lequel on a placé volontairement
une dent de mammouth donc c'est le crâne
en lui-même ressemble plutôt à un crâne
de loup donc il ressemble pas vraiment
un chien mais le fait que des êtres
humains ont pensé que cet animal était
suffisamment important pour mériter
qu'on lui place un objet rituel dans la
gueule au moment où on l'enterre ça ça
montre que ce loup c'était pas n'importe
quel loup c'était probablement un loup
en voie de chienification de
domestication devrais-je dire donc on a
ces deux hypothèses et donc cette
hypothèse ferait naître le chien par
définition à l'époque où les gens
étaient encore chasseurs-cueilleurs il y
avait pas encore de la révolution
néolithique était encore 20 à 30 000 ans
20 à 30 000 ans de là donc là c'est et
c'est donc ces deux hypothèses vous
imaginez bien que en fonction de si on
privilégie l'une ou l'autre ça donne une
narration une histoire à la
domestication du chien une fonction à la
domestication du chien qui est
complètement différent si vous avez une
domestication du chien à la révolution
néolithique ou juste avant la révolution
néolithique c'est pas du tout la même
histoire que si vous avez une
domestication du chien bien bien bien
bien avant
la naissance de l'agriculture et aussi
si vous avez une domestication du chien
chez Homo sapiens il y a 40000 ans
ça veut dire que
Néandertal a rencontré Homo sapiens qui
avait déjà domestiqué le chien
et ça pour expliquer comment ça se fait
que Homo sapiens était à dominer
Néandertal suffisamment pour que
Néandertal s'éteigne mais pas homo
sapiens alors même que Néandertal jouait
à domicile je le rappelle c'est c'est
peut-être c'est peut-être important
c'est peut-être important le fait
d'avoir eu des chiens que les chasseurs
cueilleurs sapiens aient eu des chiens
pour les aider à chasser et pas
Néandertal donc tout ça c'est tout ça
c'est très important arrivé à dater
l'origine de la domestication du chien
c'est très important et donc on a un
nouveau fossile qui vient du Pays Basque
espagnol
et des chercheurs donc essentiellement
d'Espagne on fait des analyses
génétiques pour identifier les ossements
parce que c'est très difficile
d'identifier quand on est vraiment à la
racine de la domestication du d'un
animal c'est vraiment difficile de
distinguer l'animal domestiqué de
l'animal sauvage qui lui a donné
naissance
et on est donc ils ont fait des analyses
génétiques pour pouvoir identifier quel
chien à quel chien ils avaient à faire
et ils ont fait des datations et ça ça
leur a permis de dire qu'ils ont
découvert ni plus ni moins que le plus
vieux chien d'Europe et le plus vieux
chien d'Europe à 17000 ans au Pays
Basque
et ben des facto ça invalide une origine
du chien à 10.000 ans voilà c'est
l'origine de la domestication du chien à
10000 ans des facto elle elle meurt donc
une origine néolithique du chien bam
après jusqu'à 17000 ans ça reste valide
mais là on est à 17000 ans au Pays
Basque pas à l'endroit où on s'imagine
que le chien est censé avoir été
domestiqué donc il est
de par cette découverte il est plus que
probable que le chien a été domestiqué
ailleurs bien plutôt que ça et donc
cette découverte là elle est très
importante parce que elle indique assez
clairement que le chien a été domestiqué
il y a très longtemps par des chasseurs
cueilleurs on sait pas exactement la
date mais ces chasseurs-cueilleurs en
tout cas il y a 17000 ans avaient
atteint le Pays Basque et il est fort
probable évidemment que ce soit les
chasseurs-cueilleurs qui venaient
du Moyen-Orient
on ne sait pas où a eu lieu la
domestication du chien en tout cas c'est
pas avec cette étude là qu'on va pouvoir
le déterminer ça c'est clair mais
maintenant on a quand même une base
solide pour dire bon c'est pas la
révolution néolithique parce que la
révolution néolithique elle a lieu ici
7000 ans plus tard
7 à 8000 ans plus tard donc on est
clairement on est clairement pas sur le
même timing ni sur la même géographie on
est sur définitivement ce sont des
chasseurs cueilleurs qui ont domestiqué
donc cette étude là elle est extrêmement
importante pour nous permettre de mieux
comprendre la domestication du chien et
Dieu fait l'origine des chiens
on repart sur un article paruchan
nightcher dans science-fic report
décidément ils en ont publié un paquet
et on part sur une étude qui est plutôt
intéressante parce qu'elle nous dit que
les animaux à petits cerveau
étaient plus prone à l'extinction de la
fin du Quaternaire donc l'extinction
fini quaternaire c'est l'extinction qui
a commencé il y a 10000 ans et qui se
continue aujourd'hui donc cette
extinction c'est l'extinction qui a
commencé avec la fin de la glaciation
basiquement et donc il y a 10 000 ans
l'extinction fin quaternaire commence et
apparemment ce sont les animaux avec un
cerveau plus petit qui sont qui ont
disparu les premiers en tout cas c'est
ce que cette étude nous nous suggère
j'ai regardé ça m'intéresse ça touche à
l'évolution du cerveau donc j'ai bien
regardé cette étude et j'y ai rien vu
j'y ai vu aucun défaut particulier c'est
à dire que je suis
pas complètement contre l'idée que les
animaux un petit cerveau sont ceux qui
s'éteignent les premiers ils ne
fournissent absolument pas d'explication
à pourquoi c'est le cas voilà ça tient
en deux phrases c'est les deux phrases
de conclusion c'est nous concluons que
les animaux à Gros Cerveau avait une
meilleure chance de survie à la fin du
Quaternaire c'est ce que leur donner
leur indique bien que la taille du corps
a clairement un effet important et la
taille du corps a un effet important
puisque les animaux à petit cerveaux
sont généralement des animaux de taille
corporelle élevées plus vous avez un
plus vous avez un gros corps plus votre
taille de cerveau est petite en
comparaison donc et on sait que
l'extinction quaternaire affecte
essentiellement la mégaphone donc les
animaux agro cordes donc les animaux
avec un cerveau comparativement plus
petit ceci dit ils ont corrigé pour
l'effet de la taille du corps sur leurs
données c'est quelque chose qu'on sait
faire statistiquement parlant enlever
l'effet de la taille du corps mais même
en pour ça on le sait qu'il y a toujours
un effet de la taille du corps on
n'arrive jamais à s'en débarrasser
complètement donc là ce qu'ils font dans
cette phrase c'est reconnaître cet effet
là et bien que la taille du corps soit
clairement l'effet le plus important
nous distille la taille de cerveau a
clairement fait partie des choses
sélectionnées
positivement je veux dire la taille du
cerveau permet en effet d'expliquer
quelles sont les espèces de grande
taille qui avait le plus de chances de
survivre c'est à dire que dans leur jeu
de données ce sont les espèces de grande
taille qui ont survécu sont celles qui
avaient le plus gros cerveau voyez donc
même en prenant la taille du corps en
compte même au sein des espèces de
grande taille et bien ce sont celles qui
ont le plus gros cerveau qui survivent
donc c'est exactement ce que je viens de
vous expliquer un cerveau
les espaces à grands cerveau avaient
plus de chance de s'adapter alors c'est
ça c'est la seule phrase qui explique
peut-être éventuellement pourquoi ces
espèces agro cerveaux qui se sont qui
ont survécu les espèces à gros cerveaux
avaient plus de chance peut-être de
s'adapter rapidement au changement
climatique et à la pression sélective
imposée par le nouveau prédateur humain
voilà c'est la seule phrase qui fait qui
donne éventuellement une explication au
patron observé le patron observé c'est
juste les espèces à plus gros cerveau
survivre mieux que les espèces à petits
cerveaux même à taille égale même à
taille de corps égale et donc ce qu'ils
disent
c'est que peut-être un gros cerveau
vous rend plus intelligent et que cette
intelligence inclut notamment une plus
grande flexibilité au niveau de votre
comportement qui vous permet de vous
adapter au changement climatique et à
l'arrivée de l'être humain et à
l'expansion humaine voilà c'est tout ce
qu'ils disent c'est la seule explication
qu'il fournisse
on va rappeler quand même que la taille
de cerveau c'est un truc qui est corrélé
à beaucoup beaucoup de choses il y a pas
l'intelligence encore une fois quand on
dit taille de cerveau en paléontologie
on saute immédiatement sur l'explication
de l'intelligence il y a pas que
l'intelligence qui est corrélée à un
gros cerveau il y a aussi plein d'autres
choses notamment votre taux de
reproduction votre
longévité donc la longévité les animaux
qui ont un gros cerveau sont aussi ceux
qui vivent le plus longtemps donc il y a
plein d'autres facteurs qui pourraient
être utilisés et là bon on pourrait leur
reprocher d'avoir sauté immédiatement
sur l'explication c'est l'intelligence
mais en l'occurrence ils le font que
dans une phrase de conclusion sans
vraiment élaborer dessus donc on va pas
non plus leur jeter la pierre quoi c'est
on voit bien que l'article le but du jeu
de l'article c'était pointé du doigt le
patron sans discuter sans discuter des
processus qui ont liés à ce patron en
question
bon bah puisqu'on parle gros cerveau et
intelligence on va terminer avec les
primates
terminons avec les primates et c'est le
nouvel article paru dans PNS grande
revue de de science en général publié
quand dans PNS quand on n'est pas
léontologues c'est un grand c'est un
grand honneur donc là en l'occurrence
ils ont utilisé des fossiles sud-africa
et des fossiles d'Afrique de l'Est des
fossiles de primates
cercopith et coïtes qu'on appelle des
djelladas donc le genre c'était
repiticus les jelladas ce sont des
joueurs de babouin mais qui sont
totalement herbivores ils sont très très
poilus et donc cette Gelada ils sont
très intéressants parce que en Afrique
de l'Est on les voit évoluer très vite
on voit leur évolution notamment leurs
adaptations dentaires évoluaient très
très vite et elles sont très ses
adaptations en fait l'apparition de ces
adaptations et cette évolution elle est
très bien calibrée par les séries
volcaniques qu'on a et qui est chaque
couche volcanique permettant de dater
très précisément les fossiles donc on a
cette alternance fossiles couches
volcanique facile couche volcanique
fossile couche volcanique qui permet de
dater du coup de donner un
une marge on va dire de date très
précise sur les fossiles en Afrique de
l'Est donc ce qu'ils ont fait c'est que
à partir des dates données à ces
fossiles en Afrique de l'Est ils ont
extrapolé ça en Afrique du Sud pour
arriver à dire bah écoutez puisqu'on a
cette évolution qui est bien calibrée
dans le temps des djadas donc ici c'est
les plus vieux 4 millions d'années ici
c'est les plus récents 0 donc c'est un
graphe qui se lit à l'envers en fait au
lieu d'aller du plus vieux à gauche au
plus récent à droite on va du plus
récent à droite à gauche pardon au plus
vieux à droite c'est tellement contre
intuitif que du coup même moi je me
plante mais bref et donc on voit les
djelada qui partent il y a 4 millions
d'années de d'animaux relativement petit
tels que mesuré sur la taille de leurs
dents jusqu'à des animaux relativement
grands et c'est vraiment minute vous
voyez c'est c'est très très c'est une
augmentation de taille qui est très très
régulière alors avec une certaine
dispersion évidemment on reste sur de le
on reste sur des entités des entités qui
sont biologiques on reste sur des êtres
vivants ça ne suit pas des règles très
strictes évidemment si on reste sur de
la règle statistique mais pas strict
mais on voit là c'est quand même c'est
l'évolution dans son dans sa plus belle
c'est la nageaise dans sa plus belle
dans sa plus belle forme puisque là on
voit une évolution depuis la sous-espèce
d'Artiges jusqu'à l'espèce liquide qui a
lieu de façon totalement vous voyez
c'est totalement graduel quoi c'est la
nageaise sous sa plus belle forme
l'évolution de droite doit sous vos yeux
documentés par le registre fossile on
peut pas faire mieux que ça on peut pas
faire mieux que ça à part peut-être
moins de dispersion autour de autour des
droites de régression à la limite mais
mais c'est tout c'est tout on peut pas
faire mieux que ça en matière de preuve
de l'évolution là on voit la morphologie
qui se transforme on voit nos géladas
augmenter de taille sur 4 millions
d'années en direct c'est magnifique
c'est magnifique et donc à partir de
cette calibration qui a été faite sur
les Jedi de ils ont pris les jelladas de
d'Afrique du Sud qui sont retrouvés dans
des grottes et en faisant ça
et en faisant ça et en regardant
notamment la taille de leurs dents
ils ont réussi à dater les grottes vu
que on sait que les jelladas évoluent de
façon très très régulière et en ayant
suffisamment dedans de djellada parce
qu'il faut quand même avoir beaucoup de
beaucoup d'échantillons comme je vous
l'ai dit il y a une certaine dispersion
autour de autour des droites de
régression donc une certaine dispersion
autour de la moyenne donc ça donne une
marge d'erreur donc il y a que en
calculant une moyenne que vous allez que
vous allez arriver à avoir une datation
du coup qui va être précise mais voyez
c'est tellement régulier c'est tellement
linéaire c'est tellement beau que il
suffit de prendre des dents de les
mesurer pour pouvoir dire quel âge a la
dent et ce qui a de fantastique en fait
c'est que les donc les grottes en
Afrique du Sud on a beaucoup de mal à
les dater mais on a quand même réussi à
les dater de façon différente et donc ce
qu'il y a de formidable avec cette
datation au Gelada c'est que elle est
complètement elle donne des résultats
qui sont complètement cohérents avec les
datations qui ont été faites autrement
par d'autres méthodes notamment des
méthodes directes de datation comme le
plomb l'uranium les méthodes uranium
plomb qui sont basées sur la
désintégration radioactive c'est très
difficile de faire ça sur les grottes
parce que il y a pas beaucoup d'uranium
plomb dans les grottes on trouve
légèrement ça dans la calcite c'est ce
qui est marqué ici
on trouve aussi un peu de de magnétisme
de Paléo magnétisme donc on peut aussi
dater les grottes de cette façon là mais
c'est pareil c'est difficile parce que
la stratigraphie des grottes est
extrêmement compliquée à comprendre en
fait donc c'est très important d'avoir
plusieurs sources de datation sur ces
sur ces fossiles de enfin sur ces dépôts
dans les grottes d'Afrique du Sud c'est
notamment important parce qu'on y trouve
des hominés et qu'on veut savoir à quel
point ils sont vieux nos hominidés et
donc là c'est merveilleux parce que ça a
le même âge avec les jelladas on trouve
le même âge qu'avec les méthodes uranium
plomb et avec les méthodes de
recoupement
Paléo magnétique donc ça c'est
juste impressionnant en fait que les que
l'évolution se comporte à ce point
commun une horloge dans le cas des
djellada tellement comme une horloge
qu'on peut dater à partir justement du
gras évolutif c'est juste d'une beauté
c'est d'une beauté ahurissante
et pour conclure l'annonce qui a été
faite juste avant que j'enregistre le
Paléo news du coup il y a pas de
publication il y a rien du tout c'est la
découverte de charbon de bois dans la
grotte ou aumône-alidie a été découvert
donc au modèlei rappelez-vous petit
homininet qui a vécu il y a 200 300
millions 200 300000 ans pas 300 millions
d'années
c'est une grenouille non non il a vécu
il y a 200 300000 ans Mona Lady et pour
l'instant les a retrouvés que dans une
seule dans un seul système de grotte on
va dire qui est la grotte rising star
avec plusieurs chambres à l'intérieur
c'est pour ça qu'on parle d'un système
de grotte et donc dans la grotte rising
star on vient enfin de découvrir des
charbons de bois qui pourraient
expliquer comment ça se fait qu'au mona
ledis est enfoncé si profondément dans
ce système de grotte parce que on avait
un peu de mal à comprendre comment
allez-y s'était retrouvé là notamment
dans les hypothèses il y a que un dépôt
rituel des cadavres alors rituel ou pas
d'ailleurs ça c'est une grande questions
parce qu'on peut aussi se débarrasser
des cadavres sans en avoir rien à cirer
c'est juste une question sanitaire j'ai
envie de dire mais bref
on se demandait comment c'est cadavres
avaient fini là quoi et du coup si on a
du charbon de bois bah ça veut dire
comme on avait dit pouvait faire du feu
et si au monnaie pouvait faire du feu il
pouvait très bien aller profondément
dans les systèmes de grotte sans trop se
soucier de se casser la tronche dans les
trous donc ça c'est la première chose et
la deuxième chose c'est aussi que Mona
Lady est un hominé avec un cerveau
relativement petit en tout cas pour le
genre Homo il a un cerveau de l'ordre de
600 700 cm3 donc même comparé à Homo
habilis c'est pas beaucoup et
s'ils sont 600 à 700 cm3 c'est la moitié
de Homo erectus et donc on s'attendait
pas à ce que Mona est dit de fait avec
son petit cerveau
maîtrise le feu et ça c'est quelque
chose d'intérêt alors il maîtrise le feu
parce qu'on a vraiment retrouvé des
enfin ce qu'ils disent en tout cas dans
les annonces qu'ils ont faites pour
l'instant uniquement sur Twitter
donc la science sur Twitter on va pas
lui donner non plus une crédibilité trop
trop gigantesque mais bon c'est lit
Burger et son équipe qui ont annoncé ça
donc c'est c'est eux les seuls et
uniques personnes qui travaillent sur le
site donc on est obligé de les croire de
croire ce qu'ils disent quoi qu'il
arrive on est obligé de leur faire
confiance donc ils ont retrouvé des
foyers et ça c'est foyer ça montre une
utilisation du feu maîtrisé c'est pas
seulement du feu qui a été collecté à la
suite d'un orage par exemple donc ça
c'est ou d'un feu de forêt quoi c'est
important de de remarquer que c'est du
feu maîtrisé donc cette utilisation du
feu maîtrisé pour un nominé qui a un
cerveau de 600 cm3 c'est inattendu c'est
inattendu et la seule fois où ça avait
été évoqué c'était possiblement asward
crans ou pour l'instant le seul hominidé
qu'on a retrouvé c'est parenthropus et
là on a effectivement des traces de
brûlures sur des ossements mais pas de
feu maîtrisé
donc là aumône allez dit possiblement à
encore des bonnes chances de nous
surprendre mais on attendra pareillement
comme pour le congrès de la svp on
attendra quand même qu'une véritable
publication sorte voilà c'était pas les
news je vous remercie de l'avoir suivi
n'oubliez pas de vous abonner pour ne
rien manquer d'anciens et je vous dis à
très bientôt
[Musique]